When I give £10 in charity and it is
consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a raq, then you've
put your money into something permanent,
which is a endowment that continues to
give on your behalf until the day you
meet Allah subhana wa tala. Subhan
Allah. That is
amazing. I legacy brothers and sisters,
we want you to build a legacy with your
saddaka. Where will your donation be
going? events, global events inspiring
the iman of millions around the world.
Education, free Quran lessons, free
lectures, free reminders. Number three,
media content for kids, educational
shows, spiritual Islamic shows online,
brothers and sisters. Go to the link in
donate in this blessed 10 days
inshallah. May Allah bless you
guys. Asalam allayikum brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Usually I go
to sleep and wake up for f then go back
to sleep. Uh this time I thought uh stay
up for I saw a video of a dirt bag. Uh
you guys know this dirt bag. The biggest
sellout. The biggest sellout I've ever
seen in my life. He's in London. If
anyone knows where he is, if anyone
comes across him at any moment, please
message me on Instagram. I want to speak
to him face to face. Please. I want to
express my feelings to him face to face
or legal. Uh no, it's not a death threat
or anything like that. Please don't get
it twisted. I just want to have a I just
want to see him. Anyways, here is his
video of um in the future. So, he's
going to say this is the future of
Israel and uh Palestine um you know
coexisting. Let's see, you know, he has
this thing and let's see what we can
take from this in. Yeah, cuz he's
betrayed the Palestinian his own people
in the past. He's currently betraying
them and now he's talking about the
future. Let's see if he's betrayed them
in the future as well. You know, with
him is consistency is key. Betrayal of
consistency is key. Let's see what he
has. But before that, there's just one
little clip that I want to vote to then
go to the comment section. It's very
hilarious actually. Yeah, this is NASA's
future for Palestine and Gaza in Yeah.
Let's see what we take out of this
video. But just before we go to the
video, here's another video and I just
want to tell you where this guy's mind
is at. Yeah, we're just flipping fuzzy
uh curly hair. Yes, we're going to
straighten up some facts here.
Palestinians in the world. It also has a
large Jewish population and it's in
Latin America. This is Chile. So, I came
all the way to Chile to show you this.
Chile. This guy makes me sick. Wall.
This guy makes me sick, bro. Wah. I hope
I come across a face to face.
Wah.
Anyways, a coexistence festival. My
friends and I put together one night
that brings together Palestinians and
Jews to coexist. And honestly, everyone
was scared to attend. The Jews were
scared for their life. Everyone was
scared to attend. The Jews were scared
for their life. Look at this
scaremongering. Why the hell would the
Jews be
scared in Chile? Yes. Why? Why? Okay.
The Jews are scared for their life.
There's a given like, you know, it's
just this thing like like Jews, they
make it's very antiatic to make Jews
like, you know, they're weak people.
They're not they're not you can't make
every Jew a weak person. They're not. I
mean, let's be honest, in the time of
the prophetam in the battle of Katar,
there were some warrior Jews. So to make
these Jews like passive, weak, you know,
they can't defend themselves. It's
nonsense, you know. Let's let's just be
honest here, okay? You can't you can't
brush everyone with the same brush.
Well, let's see for the Palestinian.
What does he see for the Palestinians?
The Palestinians were scared of the peer
pressure. Ah, the Jews are scared for
their life. He means
Zionists and the the Palestinians are
scared of the radicals. Ah, so the
Palestinians are not scared for their
life. Uh, who's being massacred here?
the Palestinians or the Jews? Yeah. Or
the Zionists who just been massacred.
The Palestinians. If there's anyone that
should be scared for their life by
looking at place like Canada, that uh
that that Jewish guy in America, he went
and shot two individuals thinking
they're Palestinian, but he realized
they were his own Zionist fellow. Uh
then the woman who tried to drown a
drown a group of a mother and her child.
Um and you name it, the list goes on.
You don't see Palestinians, pro
Palestinians going like genuine pro
Palestinians going and doing these acts
against. So if there's anyone that
should be scared for their life, not I'm
saying they shouldn't be like of course
there are people who antic 100%. I'm not
talking about that. But generally
looking at what's going on with the
media, it's the the the the Palestinians
are but no, the Palestinians are scared
of the radical Muslims. Anyways, let's
cut the this so you get just an idea.
Yeah. Of this curly head flipping clown.
Yeah. Okay. He looks a bit like the the
Yes. Anyways, so let's go to this actual
video of his future. What he thinks
about the Palestinian um Israel. Check
this out, guys.
48 to show you the future I imagine for
Israel and Palestine. Yes, the the Let's
see what he imagines for Palestine.
Yeah, most likely even in 2048, this guy
will be a sellout coward backstabber who
sells out his people. Okay, most likely
nothing's going to change, but let's do
inshallah. May Allah subhah guide him or
destroy him.
It's
2048. They don't launch rockets. They
launch
satellites. They don't dig tunnels. They
build hotels. You can't make this up.
They don't launch rockets. They They
launch rockets to space. They don't
build tunnels. They build
hotels. You know, I'm trying I'm
starting to believe this guy is a
Zionist. He's not a Palestinian. He's a
Zionist or he's the one of the most inf
he's got the biggest inferiority complex
ever. You I don't know if you guys
remember that video where he's sitting
down somewhere in the west the West Bank
or something like that in somewhere in
probably in Tel Aviv and some Jewish man
and you know young kid who's been
brainwashed radicalized walk past him
and start seeing this Arab terrorist
etc. This the reason why he doesn't live
in in the West Bank or in Israel because
he knows what they really think of him.
He knows how they despise him. Yes. And
here he's like you know they don't throw
rockets. The UN chart has made it very
clear that uh the resistance has a right
to armed defense, armed resistance. They
have that right. Any human being on
earth on earth. Yes. Okay. Put Hamas to
aside. The resistance has a right to
self-defense. It's in the UN charter.
It's made very clear any human being has
a right to defend their homeland. Any
human being. But not with this dirt bag.
Nope. Let's carry on. And for the first
time in
generations, people give peace a chance.
People give peace a chance. Yes. People
give who gets spat on in Jerusalem, in
Israel, Christians. Who gets treat
mistreated? The Zionist radical Jews,
radical ones who are spitting on
Christians, cursing the Muslims. Yes.
And we're not saying all. So you should
go and tell them to fix the act.
between Israel and Palestine. This was a
dream before. Now it's reality. Signed,
recognized by the world.
Even the Pope cried. This is too good.
Too good. The pope is probably the
probably if that's the case in 2014, the
pope finds out that you're you've
repented for being a sellout. That's why
he's probably crying. This too good to
be true. Yeah. He's crying that you're
still a sellout. Okay. And this is AI
generated, by the way. Yeah. This is all
AI generated. Finally, two states for
two people. Two states for two people.
Like the Jews and the Christians and the
Muslims have not been living in the same
lands for centuries. Yes. Muslims have
defended the Jews and the Christians in
these lands. Yes. When the Christians
did not want any Jews in those lands,
Muslims armies brought families of
Jewish people. Yes. When the Christians
were desecrating. Yes. And this is where
antismism comes. Come with the crusaders
from the Christians. They're the ones
who hated the Jews because they killed
their god. Okay, it's not from Islam.
But anyways, let's carry on. Then more
states join. Lebanon, Saudi Arabia,
Syria, Yemen, and Iran. It's been a long
time coming.
But we made it. Muslim tourists book
their
flights. They come for a run in Tel
Aviv.
They come for a run for Tel Aviv. more
more like probably running for their
lives so they don't get massacred. Yeah.
Okay. That's what's going on. And look
guys, is this something that I didn't
want to happen? Of course I do. Yes. But
under the land of Palestine. That land
belongs to Palestine. And I want the
Jews, the Christians, and the Muslims
living in that land as they did hundreds
of years, thousands of years as
Palestine. Not Israel. Yes. As
Palestine. Because those lands belong to
them. And that's a fact. Yes. I want
them to coexist together. This would be
a dream come true for anybody, but not
the way he describes. No, because he is
a sellout Zionist
shill. They pray in Al Axa
mosque and stay in hotels in
Gaza. Jews and Muslims marry. Jews and
Muslims marry. Okay. Yeah. That's not a
problem. The prophetam his one of his
wife was ethnically Jewish.
Alhamdulillah.
So yeah, but I practiced in Jew by the
way. A chased Jew woman
and the mothers approve. Well, at least
the kids will be Jewish, right? Uh
interesting. Why can't the kids be uh
Palestinian? Yes. Why can't they be
Muslim? Why not? Why not? I know she's
trying to insinuate that cuz the mothers
cuz for them a Jewish is you're a Jew by
your mother, not by your father. And you
know, but anyways, the MSAD is out of
business. So, ah, the MSAD is out of
business. What happened? Is there no
Palestinians left to kill? Is that why
it went out of business? Yeah. I didn't
realize, oh, there's all the
Palestinians are gone. Yeah. Maybe this
what he's talking about. Yeah. Yeah. You
get rid of the Palestinians, bring other
Arabs. Uh, you know, maybe that's what
he's talking about, you know. Oh, M is
out of business. But let's see why it's
out of business. Very interesting.
There's one little part that's very
interesting. Yeah. Let me see what if I
think what it is. It opens a museum.
This was used many years ago, but no one
needs to use it now.
interested. It's up in a museum, you
know. Uh is it has it got all the body
parts and the limbs of the children that
was massacred? Yes. Museum. Like the way
he makes it seem it's like saying it's
like how can I explain to you? It's like
haram in in in Somalia. Yes. Al Shabbab.
Yeah. And then we say, "Oh yeah, the
al-Shabaab don't exist anymore." And
they've opened the museum. They make it
seem like, yeah, you know, Mossad like
is a legitimate Mossad is a massacre
machine, a genocidal maniacs, okay, who
hack into they just trying to hack into
was it Boris Johnson, the Queen's
apartment? These guys are everywhere.
Yes, these are the guys are the most
disgusting, despicable people. And not
only that, in that thing, have you
looked closely, guys? Is that a pager?
Was it me? Am I seeing I don't know what
it means by they're not used anymore. Is
that a pager? I don't know cuz they seen
it as a museum. Like is this a page that
like you know he's trying to indirectly
say you know basically you know this is
what people don't like what's that why
is there a page there must museum yeah
the ones they remember they put they
press the button and innocent people
many people got uh uh hurt and injured
and even some died and yet the protests
remain this is not what we want not
peace it will not last smaller and more
irrelevant smaller and then more
irrelevant let's see do they look like
Jews see let's look closer are they
Jewish people uh one second Let's have a
look. Uh oh. No, they're not. They're
hijabis. They're all They all
Palestinians. So, it's the Palestinians
that are that are the troublemakers. You
d if I knew I would not get into legal
trouble, I would spit in your face, bro.
Now, wall, if I knew, there's not going
to be ramifications, etc. Wall, I would
spit in your face if I saw you in
person. Wahi. Wahi. You are the biggest
donkey, bro. I'm going to call you
donkey. You a donkey. Even donkey.
Donkey has more dignity. Please look at
this. He's putting the Palestinians as
the
troublemakers. No justice, no peace.
Yes, justice is the most important thing
in Islam. The greatest injustice on this
earth is to associate partners to God
and give credit to other beings when
Allah is the one who created heavens and
earth. And then injustice carries on
with oppressing other people. Yes. And
no nation will prosper if it's
oppressing others. And look how he's
making from the rockets to the tunnels
is the dig at Palestinians. Dig at
Palestinians. Dig at Palestinians. Yeah.
And now he's made them like they're the
ones who like just as if they're the
alienated the other. And look at them.
They're not Jews. Yeah. They all look at
they're all Muslim hijabis. Who? Look.
Palestinians. Come make yourself up,
bro. You dirt bag. You're in the UK.
Yeah. I come across you, bro.
ever. In 2048, the land didn't change,
but the people did. You want some? Thank
Thank you. You're right. The land didn't
change. People like you sellouts
changed. Yes. Cowards. You're going to
go down history as a sellout. And by the
way, alhamdulillah, he's lost so much
following. It's unbelievable the amount
of views his video gets. He has totally
lost it. May Allah destroy your wealth.
May Allah humiliate you. the way those
Palestinian children have been blown
into pieces and you are on the side of
those genocidal maniacs. May Allah break
you into pieces. Wall I make dua to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and this is
weakness for me. May Allah guide you.
May or may Allah break you man. May
Allah humiliate you. May that money you
make that they pay you to to be a
sellout. Yes. May it make you suffer.
May you not
prosper. You sell out. There is no issue
with this video. I have no problem. The
Christians and the Jews and Muslims,
they live in peace. Wallah, it's a dream
come true. The way you portray this
video is the problem here.
This sounds like a dream only possible
to imagine with AI, but it doesn't have
to be.
Remember, if you will
it, it is no dream. It is no dream.
Okay, now let's just quickly go to
comments. Okay, let's just leave this
now. Let's go to comments. I just want
to show you guys the comments, guys.
This is where it gets really
interesting. Okay, so the first comment
is um notice who is in favor of this and
who is strongly opposed. Is there a
pattern? Yeah, space who's opposing this
like people like me and you I oppose
them living in peace. No, no, no, no,
no, no. That's not the issue here. We're
opposing the way he is vilifying the
Palestinians. The way he's turning a
blind eye to what Israel is doing. That
is our point here. And what does he say?
The inferiority man with inferiority
complex chief. Sadly, there is. But also
notice who produced this. He's talking
about himself and you know picking me
please and I'm you know you flipping
sell out. Next one he goes we've been
dreaming it for years and then we woke
up to October
7th. I mean you can't make the stuff up
bro. They think it started October 7th.
It's like me massacring someone's family
members beating them up every time I see
them. And subhan Allah one day they they
they retaliate. Yes they retaliate.
Right or wrong the retaliation. Let's
say it's right or wrong. argument safe
they retaliate anyone their sound mind
will say hold on a second you have been
doing this didn't start then this
started way before that's the point I'm
not trying to justify anything I'm
saying we need to look at the root of
the problem if you want the solution to
this conflict yes okay u anyway somebody
goes underneath I laugh so hard and then
he goes keep laughing serious next what
does this guy mean this dirt bag next
comment he goes this video will be the
ultimate filter of you who you should
befriend and who you should run away
from who should run away from you bro
everyone's run away from bro you can't
expose the left right center yeah you
can't expose left that Allah is
humiliating you and this is good this
video shows you that you are a little
shanan next comment no peace without
justice he goes you're in the video what
he saying is true there is no peace
without justice simple as
that and this one that's a very nice
vision my friend we had it too but then
October 7 happened and the same people
who've helped them from the IO side have
been the first people to take the hit. I
personally lost all hope for that to
happen. He goes does don't lose all
hope. We can build a better future. He's
got a Z talking about it as if things
started October 7th forgetting about all
the massacres that they committed. And
this dirt donkey is saying don't lose
all hope. We can build a better
future. May Allah deal with you daily.
You're in the UK. Alhamdulillah.
Inshallah come across you. Inshallah
come across you.
brother and sisters. That's all I'm
going to say. Inshallah, this coward,
backstabbing, betraying sellout, who's
been doing this in the past, who's still
doing it now, and in 2048, he will
probably be doing it again if he doesn't
repent and change. May Allah humiliate
him. That's all I'm going to say, bro.
Inshallah, the whole world is woken up.
It is the beginning of the end of Israel
and Zionist. And inshallah we'll return
back to where Palestinians, Jews,
Muslims, Christians will live side by
side in harmony until Jesus, the real
Messiah comes. The Messiah that we
accept. Yes, that the Jews do not
believe in. We believe he's the Messiah.
We believe he's going to come and there
will be justice in sisters. Till next
time.
or better